okay
good morning
and thank you oh dad and ron and all the
organizers
for the invitation it's really a great
pleasure to be here
so today we are going to do justice
justice to professor suzanne berget
suzanne was a postdoc with phil sharp
just at the time that they discovered
the introns
she then got an appointment at houston
she published very nicely
but in
1991 she made a mistake
she wrote an opinion letter
in this opinion letter
she suggested that there are two
different mechanisms
by which the splicing machinery
defined intron
or exons as the spliced unit
when the introns are short the slicing
machinery place the splicing factors
across the intron
failing to do so
is leading to interim definite to
internal retention
and she called such a mechanism in term
definition
however when the introns are long
the splicing machinery placed the same
splicing factors across the axon
and failing to properly recognize the
axon is leading to exon skipping
which is the most abundant type of
functional alternative splicing in
higher eukaryotic organisms
and she called this mechanism excellent
definition
so intern definition is the recognition
of the internals the splice unit and
excel definition is the recognition of
the axon
as the spliced unit
she tried to submit this opinion letter
to many journals
for more than one year
and all the editor rejected
this opinion later under the basis that
this is baseless
eventually
alan weiner who was the editor of mcb
decided that she deserved a chance and
she published this paper
however two years after that she left
the splicing field all together
but then
more and more genes
started to be sequenced
more and more mutations leading to
genetic disorders and cancer were
accumulated and she turned it turned out
that she was most probably right
because there are certain mutations that
are leading to
internal retention
and other mutations that are leading to
exon skipping
however for the last 30 years we don't
have a clue how the splicing machinery
defined this is the splice unit compared
to this one
so our story started
when we decided to examine gene
architecture
in regions of high
versus slow gc content in the human
genome
so the human genome composed from
isocores of high shown here by the hot
colors
alongside
regions of low gc content regions
and to make a long story short we found
two different architectures
genes that are located in low gc content
regions got very long flanking introns
with low gc content
however the exon
contain a much higher level
of gc content compared to the flanking
in tonic sequences so we call this
architecture the differential this is
the differential of the gc content
whereas genes that are located in high
gc content regions got a totally
different architecture
the overall gc content is much higher
but there is no differential gc content
between the introns and the exons
and the introns are under selection to
remain short
we call this architect to the level
architecture
so in the human genome we have two
different architectures
for genes that are located in low gc
content region compared to genes that
are located in high gc content regions
is this is something that is unique to
us of course not but this is unique to
warm blooded organisms
meaning mammals and avians in all of
them we have the separation into two
different gene architectures
whereas in
cold-blooded organism we have one
genocitic tour only
low gc content in the introns much
higher gc content in the exos
so in collaboration with talpko from tel
aviv university we reconstructed
the ancestral structure
which is precisely like what we see in
cold-blooded organisms
so during evolution
with the appearance of warm-blooded
organisms
genes that remain in low gc content
regions their introns were allowed to
lengthen
for example by insertion of retro
elements
and as long as they have the
differential gc content their splicing
is safe
however genes that are located in
regions that accumulated mutations that
elevated
the gc content
the differential gc content was
eliminated
but the introns are under selection to
remain short
so the separation into two gene
architectures ring a bell that we might
be able to identify the internal
definition and exon definition
so the first question that we decided to
ask is where these
structures are located in the human
genome
so we use hi-c
data
with
the addition of chipset with lamin lamin
allow us to
align
the dna that is located close to the
nuclear periphery
and we build from the nuclear periphery
to the center of the nucleus the
organization
of the chromosomes
we use two additional programs one that
is using from central to the periphery
and another one that is unbiased and in
all the different programs we got the
same
story as expected
high gc content regions
are located in the nuclear center of the
nucleus and low gc content regions are
located in the nuclear periphery
then we decided to divide the nucleus
into five euclidean distances you can do
10 and you're going to get the same
results
and what we found is quite interesting
we see a linear decrease
from the center to the nuclear to the
periphery of the high gc content regions
with a similar increase in the level of
dna fragments of low gc content region
from the center of the nucleus to the
periphery so it seems that the dna is a
range in the nucleus according to the gc
content as a gradient of gc content
low gc content in the periphery
in high gc content in the center
according to the gc content profile
so what about the two structure gene
structure
in the nuclear periphery we see the
differential structure
and as we move from the nuclear
periphery to the nucleus center we see
shift in general architecture in gene
architecture so that in the nucleus
center we have the level architecture
so the dna arrangement in the nucleus
place genes with two different artillery
two one in the center the level one and
one
in the periphery
so
is this is related
is very similar to this bernardi's iso
chord thing right is this the same thing
or not do you think that these are
related and that is only what he said
okay
a lot of stuff and whatever i'm going to
say within a second he's going to write
that i'm i'm wrong so i'm not taking him
so so seriously what bernardi said that
there are isobars meaning for a fighter
though
yeah something like that and uh
what bernardis
predicted because there was no high c in
the time that he worked on it he
predicted
and this is quite supported currently
this
the high dc content in the center and
logistic company the periphery this is
already known this is unknown this is
the new stuff between them
so uh what bernard is basically is
predicted is that the high gc content
are going to be in the center of the
nucleus where the uh he predicted that
this is going to be the center for a
housekeeping genes which is not so much
okay so uh
is the two alkyna twos are basically
excellent definition and improve
definition to start to address it we ask
what is the mode of alternative splicing
and we decided just to take the outcome
of exxon definition which is exon
skipping shown here in blue
and intron retention which is indication
for us for intern definition which is in
red and as you can see in the center of
the nucleus we see mostly alternative
splicing events of intron retention
and selection against exon skipping
whereas in the three
peripheral euclidean distances we see
selection for exon sequence for exon
uh
axon skipping and selection against
internal retention so there is also
separation in the nucleus between one
one mode of alternative splicing intron
retention compared to the other mode
which is excellent skipping and how can
we validate that this is indeed
excellent definition and interim
definition
so of fear here compile a data set of
all
five prime splice side mutation this is
the five prime supply side
mutations that are associated with
cancer and are known to be affect the in
and affecting the splicing mode and you
can see that five frame spliced mutation
associated with
cancer
that are located in genes that are close
to the nucleus center
causing intron retention
whereas the same mutations that are
causing in that are located in genes
that are located close to the nuclear
periphery are causing exon skipping so
this was the indication to us that
indeed we are right
this structure the blue structure the
differential is excellent definition and
the red one is interim definition so we
decided to understand the molecular
mechanism
and for that luna who is sitting in here
in the room cloned many genes
genes that are located in the nuclear
periphery
and genes that are located in the new
class center and from each of these
genes she cloned three exons separated
by two introns
she placed all of these mini genes under
the same promoter
and inserted those minigenes in
integration site that is located close
to the nucleus center
or close to the nuclear periphery
and she used five-frame splice mutation
here and here
in order to
validate whether the splicing mode is by
exon definition or intern definition
so all the genes with the differential
gc content the mutation is causing
shifting splicing from exon inclusion to
excellence skipping indicating that the
differential structure this structure
is excellent definition whereas
in the
[Music]
red structure
all the mutations that the five-point
supply side shifted splicing from axon
inclusion to intro retention
meaning this is a internal definition
what she did was to find out what is the
structure that is needed to define exon
definition via to intern definition
she replaced in high gc content region
downstream from the five prime supply
side a fragment of 50 nucleotides from
high to low gc content region so she
generated basically the differential gc
content
and indeed splicing shifted from
internal definition to exon definition
from intron retention to exon skipping
so the differential gc content by itself
is the structure that determines if the
splicing machinery is going to select
the axon
or the intron as the spliced unit
so uh
what she noticed is that it really
doesn't matter where the gene is going
to be located close to the center or
close to the periphery as long as the
axon or the intron is constitutively
spliced meaning this is a strong
slicing a signal
the splicing is identical however once
the splicing is sub-optimal
meaning we can see some inclusion and
some skipping some intro retention and
some a
splicing of this intron this is a
sub-optimal opinion she started to see
with semi-quantitative
rt pcr differences in the inclusion
level between the center to the
periphery so in order to validate it you
perform
quantitative rt pcr
and indeed in exon skipping if the axon
is more close to the nuclear periphery
the inclusion is higher
and the other the other story for the
internal retention the farthest away
meaning it's more close to the nuclear
center the more splicing this intron is
undergoing so the location of the splice
unit is important
and here we can see a very cool story
this is rna fish
before insertion of the dna fragment
after insertion of dna fragment of low
gc content and after insertion of dna
fragment with high gc content
so whenever the high gc content was
insertion inserted into the chromosome
you can see that there is a shift
of the entire chromosome clause of the
entire loci close to the new class
center however when a low gc content was
inserted there is a shift toward the
nuclear periphery
what is happening to the genes that are
located nearby
so there is a gene that is located 110
kilo kilobase from the integration side
in this gene change both
the
alternative splicing mode
and the transcription level so shifting
a gene
from one place to another placing the
genome affect both transcription
and splicing
and in order to validate it
vanessa examined the effect of knocking
out delamin protein so la means
encore to the nuclear
envelope they hold 80 rich sequences
and by shifting them and by depleting
them we found that there
there is a
change changes in a
chromosome organization mostly
chromosomes that are located close to
the nuclear periphery are moving into
the center of the nucleus and you can
see that these changes in the splicing
in a chromosome organization affect
splicing of axel skipping in a linear
way meaning the farther away
the shift is happening more excellent
skipping
the slower or the shortest shift from
the nucleus center from the nuclear
periphery to the nuclear center more
exon inclusion so the location again of
the splice unit is very important with
respect to regulation of splicing
so to finalize here
in which the gc content is changed
because this makes it
change to the whole architecture
here
okay this is something that we are
currently doing precisely this is
this region i believe this is something
like 3kb
and the high gc content is something
like 1kb
and this was sufficient in order to
shift and to show that this the length
is really important that
the longer it is the more the shift is
by the student in the lab with precisely
the
mistakes
okay so but but most probably
and we're doing it
with respect whether the list
transcription and without transcription
okay so
to understand the molecular mechanism
of exon definition and interim
definition
we need to keep in mind that splicing is
regulated by splicing factors splicing
factors that have
rna recognition motive they bind usually
close to the region that they affect
their splicing
and in order to understand what kind of
splicing factors regulate internal
definition in excellent definition
of phil analyzed 86
i-clip data
of splicing factors
and he found that there are quite a lot
of splicing factors that prefer to bind
to high gc content genes to the level
genes and they affect their splicing
compared to a lower amount of splicing
factors that prefer to bind to the
differential architecture and this is
quite interesting
because this structure is the ancestral
structure
this structure is the new arrival that
appear only after the appearance of
warm-blooded organisms
the fact that we need
many more splicing factors in order to
regulate this new structure is
indicating that
it required a lot of regulation
so in order to understand the regulation
we collaborated with rodent chalan who
developed a wonderful program that is
called anat that is building network
interactions starting with transcription
factors ending with the splicing factor
that bind
to the target
and uh we found that there are two
different networks of proteins that
regulate exon definition and interim
definition
in interim definition the majority of
the splicing factors are rna helicases
which mean they need to open secondary
structure presumably in order to allow
the splicing machinery access to the
supply sides
however
for the uh
exon definition mechanism
the predominant proteins that are
located in this network belong to a
group of protein that are called agent
rnp
and agent rnp proteins are like
rna nucleosomes they needed in order to
squeeze long rna molecules
so there are two different regulations
regular regulatory networks one for exon
definition and another one for
intradefinition
so in order to sum up
we found that the ancestral gene
structure
look like that short introns with low gc
content much higher gc content in the
exon compared to the flanking intronic
sequences
with the appearance of avians and
mammals there was separation into two
different architectures
genes that remain in low gc content
regions
their introns were allowed to
lengthening for example by insertion of
primate-specific alu elements
and as long as they have the
differential gc content their splicing
is safe
they have a nucleosome sitting here
marking the location of the exon this is
a paper that roderick and myself
published together back to back
a few years back
there is also a very unique signature of
dna methylation on these axons and also
in this axon so a lot of story with
epigenetics
however genes that are located in
regions that
shown accumulation of gc content
the accumulation of gc content
eliminated the differential gc content
but the introns are under selection to
remain short
this structure is associated with
internal definition failing to recognize
the intron is leading to interim
retention
in the differential group
failing of recognizing the axon is
leading to exon skipping a totally
different mechanism
the dna is arranged in the nucleus in a
linear
gc content fashion
low gc content in the periphery high gc
content in the center in the periphery
we have exon definition in the center we
have intern definition so the two mode
of regulation is taking place in two
different places and there is a set of
splicing factors that are unique and
bind to this region
compared to a different set of proteins
that prefer to bind to the center of the
nucleus and to regulate intron selection
so uh
i was extremely fortunate to have
outstanding students
almost 10 of them are currently pi one
of them left yesterday
back to israel and i'm sure that many
others will be
and the first
three core first auto on this paper were
luna tamal who performed all the
experimental validation system and found
the mechanism of fira mehiri
that perform most of the bioinformatic
analysis
if at kedar that is unfortunately not
with us anymore but she bring to the lab
the high c technology and spread it all
over
and many other stories but that will
have to wait for another meeting and
thank you all for your attention
so um your statement that
low gc content is at the periphery high
gc content is an interior of the nucleus
this trend
is true but it has been refined in the
recent literature right
so the chromatin
the this type of binary separation
is too polarized it's not necessarily
what the nucleus is organized
in the nucleus there's also
some nuclear structures like
eucharist speckles where a lot of
spicing factors are located
so
okay back to back to our paper
was the paper from blair ben blanco who
analyzed the dna sequences that bind to
the speckle speckles are
site
that are enriched with splicing factors
okay
and they they are also enriched with
high juicy content sure but in the
nucleus in the interior they're also
um
it's a this is why
yeah so you know these these these type
of um i think you know
that covers i think is is has been
refined by work from like andy belmont
in the recently uh in shelby burger
pennsylvania they have done similar
experiments using psac to look at the
psychological distance between chromatin
and nuclear sparkles and also they
studied the sort of the
correlation between distance and
transcription right so there's a very
intricate connection between so my
question for you
let me try to rephrase what you're
saying you're saying basically the
transcription determined the location of
the dna of the gene in the dna
no i'm saying that
these important sub-nuclear bodies like
speckles and other crooked bodies
are serving as anchors
to organize
an organization
okay so what you're what you're showing
is i think a strong correlation between
gc content and it's spicy
but the determining factor could be
just the
subnuclear structures
what i'm applying is the gc content by
itself
most probably not related not to
transcription not the splicing not in
anything
is that they determine the gc code by
itself determine the location and indeed
there are two arm cores currently in the
literature that are starting to be built
one of them one encore is located in the
nuclear periphery this is laming or the
the protein that bind to the dna
functions bind to
and the speckles
which we are not sure yet whether they
are the second anchor that is holding
the high gc content regions but we have
very strong indications that this is
indeed two poles
that are holding
rgc content in the center low gc content
in the periphery and whenever one of
them is missing as we have shown here by
the knockout something is flipping
around
it's not based only on what we've
published your own previous papers to us
and we've
used
just dcf and got the same response
this is a very important uh story how
the dna is arranged in the piece
i guess you know against summary i think
what you see is the correlation
high low gc content with the position of
the chromatin and their nuclei in this
genome function but it may you know
there are other factors that are
involved like i've earlier worked to
show there's sequence determines
sequence motifs like from this thing and
earlier with a bosman's diesel with the
nuclear peripheral with the alignment
right so low gc content may not be the
determinant
for the position of the chromatin
to its attachment to the nuclear
porosity
[Music]
periphery so it must be
it can't be that this is not the reason
that the low gc content is located in
the periphery
we have
more evidence
get unpublished showing that this is
this is the
the cause
the the the gc content by itself
determine the gradient
one um to a hygienist
so what you are asking is tissue
specifically
from different species different species
okay um we have genes that move about a
lot what do you say comparative analysis
between the only option is to compare 3d
organization between human and mouse
because these are the two organisms that
we have sufficient amount of data high c
data
but if the regulation
is really
important
for the for the spicing
in one species
would move to a different environment
that's what we have shown we've shown
that by placing a high gc or low gc
content region in a certain position in
this genome
causing
a region or a tab let's say not the top
but this is a region of a chromosome to
shift either to the nuclear periphery or
to the nucleus center and the gene that
is located 100 kb away from this site
maybe it's in the same part maybe not
change the mode of transcription and
splicing so
i believe that that
i believe that what we've seen here is
the scaffold
of the dna
the minority the changes that you're
going to see between one cell line to
another cell line between one embryonic
stage to another embryonic stage between
one condition to another condition is
going to give a refinement of a gene
genome gene transcription and discussion
so
um
the story is even more complex because
it's like
not in all genes not in all excellence
we have a differential gc content from
both sides one of them they are
differential here and level on the other
side and
we are just starting we took
some 25
the bottom 25 percent 50 in the middle
still need to be figure out how
how the
both of these mechanisms
working together in order to
generate effective splicing
when both the exon and the flanking
introns are being selected by the
splicing machinery we are just
correcting the the tip of the iso
so regardless
in the splicing machine and other sub
networks that have been being recruited
into
longinus closer regions versus research
so what's um
so what's uh
more because your hypothesis was going
there it's just that you have more
secondary structures in the distribution
other places of this
you know
structure
what do you feel goes behind those
differences
i know
those of you that have a very sharp eyes
should have seen that in the high gc
concrete region downstream from the from
the five-gram spy side there is a peak
of much higher g sequences
uh if you guys have considered using
nanoforce sequencing uh to sequence the
rna and try to get like long high
supports and at the same time get
information about the genetic marks on
their harmony and try to
see
what do you what do you mean epigenetic
mark like rna methylation yeah there's
like over 60 different
next time next time godaddy we'll invite
my former student chadish balthy will
give you a story about it
okay i'm i'm really not there
he is an expert indeed rna methylation
in some cases mark the location of
actions
but it's
it's a very interesting story not my
feeling
so you have this hypothesis that this
g6
to show that there is a class of the
splicing factors that are specifically
or
it to splice this uh this this this
small displacing are they supported by
evolutionary analysis so are these spicy
factors
vertebrates or do you see
a difference in the evolutionary rate or
things
the older version
is much more concerned which means that
the textile definition are much more
concerned all the genes that are located
in the uh high gc content regions
underwent
duplications uh more mutations they they
are more modern dynamically
i have another question
so do you think that the genes that are
transcribed next to the periphery are
more likely to be exported
from the nucleus to the cytosol
because internal retention has been
playing a role in the regulation of
exporting an interpretation of
understanding
it's the same story like the high gc
content gyms
supposed to be the housekeeping genes
supposed to be in the center of the
nucleus
there are some support for for
whatever i know is not about
the low gc content most of the genes of
the low gc content
are a
tissue-specific
genes okay
and most of the genes that are located
close to the center
are
really indeed housekeeping genes or like
histones and stuff like that
and i don't know we had this hypothesis
with one of the gene with splicing
factor that's supposed to regulate
events that are located in the periphery
but this genome is located in the center
of democracy i'm not so sure that a lot
of still need to be done
excellent
[Music]
with
anyways
hybrid session because the next